une icône r bonjour au jour c'est un
buteur c'est un palier des changements
le vus par l'onda d'une seconde c'est un
love fait un bien énorme dans ce cas-ci
changement donc vous visiez ramassez pas
mal d'argent avec cet événement là juste
pour lire et à son public non non non
non non cela fait du bien
il est concret il était à terre il vaut
là où le monde ne vont pas moi j'ai vu
des jeunes récupérer des jeunes entre
les jeunes femmes qui étaient carrément
perdu ramener cette estime de soi c'est
le début de l' écoute c'est comme ça
qu'on est capable d'en faire des bons
citoyens
il y en a si souvent vides non mais sauf
des villes peu sorcier des gens de l'est
gagnent de rue tout ça il ya une
accréditation du ministère d'éducation
c'est pas pour rien donc celle aperçue
persévérance scolaire mais c'est le
latin ou aux gens leur dit que vous
n'êtes pas seuls et un événement comme
aujourd'hui puis évidemment je me sers
de ma notoriété parce que je crois la
cause parce que je voulais qu'on passe
un message là c'est la deuxième édition
de 12 rendre d'espoir dont vous allez
avoir douze personnalités qui vont faire
un rang et pour amasser des fonds et
puis j'ai dû en faire ce qu des rouges
et occuper de vous aussi un coût on le
voit vous aviez déjà faisceau fédéral
perd du poids quand j'étais ministre des
sports est ce que le vrai défi c'est de
maintenir un équilibre ce que je me
rends compte parce que j'ai toujours à
la blague je fais perdu 800 livres
articles et dire que révèle dans ma
ville c'est tellement vrai ce que vous
dites il faut que ça qu'on maintient
donc au monde comment on peut le
maintenir mais je pense qu'il ya une
prise de conscience qui doit être fait
là je les fais vraiment pour moi à 59 à
56 cents à 50/50 foutu je prends
conscience que ça commence par toi on
parle de salles de soin faut qu'on
s'estime à nouveau faut qu'on se donne
des paramètres qui sont réalisables
c'est pas une diète c'est une façon de
changer
c'est une nouvelle culture
natation c'est pour végétariens mais je
mange plus de légumes qu'ils mangent
moins de viande je te mange plus de
poissons sur les 8es par sion puis tu
sais par exemple de ne pas manger après
n'avoir pour vous ce nouvel état
d'esprit vous voulez pour le reste en
tout cas par une bonne partie de votre
vie parce que j'étais pubiens la fin non
le vue il aurait mangé une claque au
lycée mais vous étiez pas bien mais je
pense que tout était prêt destiné à sion
en quelque part parce que c'est une
donne comme un malade du travail ce jour
par semaine 20 trains par jour parce que
ça mange images n'ont jamais mangé 11 en
2008 soit on pioche là-dessus petit
réveil à 5h et puis faut que tu aies gt
puis je me plains pas je suis pas
victime parce que je dis c'est que tu
constates que des événements pied des
éléments qui font que t'es pas bien dans
ta peau puis à un moment donné faut tu
te retrouves tout simplement parce que
j'ai fait maintenant la question denis
coderre c est ce qu on peut garder cet
équilibre là dans le monde politique
je vous poserai même pas question je
vous la poser mais c'est ce que vous
allez retourner pour moi c'est même pas
du tout un peuple
c'est dans votre adn moi je vous connais
de l'université laurier-sainte-marie
quand gilles duceppe des actifs c'est si
vous est ce que vous pourriez garder cet
équilibre dans l'ombre politique je
pense que le monde politique comme dans
n'importe quelle fonction ou quelques
professions c'est vrai dans le milieu
médiatique vous avez un stress plus
toute la question de nouvelles continues
tout ça qu'on est con doit livrer aussi
quelque chose qui on doit être en mode
solution si tu n'atteins pas ton point
d'équilibré qui arrivera jamais et ça te
rattrape toujours
si tu as tort si ce déséquilibre là si
tu peux te donner à fond mais si tu
oublié les autres choses tu perds
quelque chose ça va être rattrapé un
moment donné ce déséquilibre a offert
qu'un support propose au travail
vous avez prendre l'analogie de la boxe
en avait mangé toute une comme madame
plan vous avez perdu
avez vous encore est ce que c'est ça la
priorité numéro un quand vous parlez du
monde politique
le municipal à l'essai de prendre une
revanche la prochaine fois c'est les
gens se présentent pour une revanche
c'est pas porter ok ça va se rattraper
non
moi je porte un nom mais moi je produis
la pige pas là-dessus même pas là pour
est ce que je me présente aux poches
profondes ce qui est inférieur mais
safran prenait une décision bientôt
c'est dans trois ans car j'ai déjà perdu
avant de perdre trois fois avant de
faire elle est peut-être les jantes et à
des nouveaux candidats professionnels
j'ai fait du mal je connaissais la
défaite une défaite fait toujours mal
mais faut la comprendre il faut
l'expliquer il faut vivre avec
mais avez-vous le goût de revenir tenter
votre chance comme maire de montréal
s'est pas dans les priorités que je lis
et aujourd'hui je ne sais pas quand ni
combien de temps pour être formés entre
les deux camps je me presse que parce
qu'il ya une échéance électorale nombre
de supports je peux pas faut regagner
faudra vous savez faire mais c'est de
l'argent au travail et sa notoriété
ça s'est fait très peu d'entre vous
savez combien de mois là mais vous êtes
conscient qu'il me met en colère c'est
trudeau derrière qui boxe ici d'ailleurs
boksic je pensais vous me demandez je
vais trouver un sénateur conservateur
n'a pas dit quand non non je le fais
déjà sinon je donnais et quand je
donnais 20 ans de ma vie et plus je sais
qu'il y en aurait besoin droit d'espérer
pas lieu demain non j'ai donné fédéral
si non fini ben fini on dit clairement
provincial je vois là je pense que les
gars j'ai toujours donné j'ai j'ai été
au fédéral j'étais au municipal
je suis même pas dans un état civil
empreintes mais l'espace cuire les pâtes
et puis il faut être clair je pas dans
un état d'esprit pour qu'on dise que ce
soit facteurs comme je le crois pas
battle doigts
vous avez le droit pardon est-ce que tu
voyais je m'en fous je crois pas je sais
que vous pensez à ça c'est sûr vous
pensé à ça tout le monde se projette
dans l'avenir puis vous dites est ce que
je me vois donc pile au final avec cette
dernière question quand vous vous
approchez d'un autre affaire quand vous
vous projetez ces municipales plus que
les deux autres mieux hors du
gouvernement
je fais beaucoup de choses sur la scène
internationale présentement tant sur la
scène locale puis je travaille
non mais je le fais beaucoup c'est vrai
ce n'est pas mon cv mais c'est là que
les villes ont un rôle à jouer c'est
majeur que montréal est une ville
exceptionnelle que j'aime d'un mot
d'ordre mais ces municipales qui sait si
le rôle hilaire où il y avait goûté
c'est important voilà ce qui me motive
c'est le service aux jeunes parfum c'est
d'aider les gens ok
cette question d'actualité la laïcité il
a quand même comme citoyen de montréal
qu'est ce que vous pensez de ce projet
de loi là qu'est ce que montréal doit
faire un jeu cohérent depuis le début le
statut de métropole il ya les réflexes
montréal il ya l'autonomie des
municipalités il ya garde je me suis
battu contre la charte des valeurs je me
suis battu contre le projet de loi de
monsieur clients c'est moi qui a sorti
la fin elle avait ce qu'on veut que les
chauffeurs d'autobus wade police de
berck où on est tous d'accord qu'il faut
donner des services à visage découvert
on est tous d'accord avec ce bel ce
qu'on signe que ça s'applique à montréal
que ça plus impliqués - réflexion rien
moi je pense que montréal est donc sans
dire qu'il n'est pas impliqué je suis je
pense qu'ils vont avoir un problème il y
en a plein ses puis venez vous avez été
correspondant parlementaire à ottawa
vous avez suivi les législations de les
législateurs il ya un vieux principe
qu'on doive être toujours en application
c'est est-ce que c'est applicable cette
voie là les anglais disent doit bel
outil est ce que cette loi là même s'il
est plein de bonnes intentions
c'est faisable est-ce que la clause
nonobstant les pros applicable c'est
comme entrer comme moi je pense que je
vais cohérent j'ai toujours dit que je
ne voit pas la pertinence de ce n'est
pas un week-end
ce cas d'air dans bon bon bon bon merci
mois de mai on va suivre ça à la
prochaine puis on va se revoir je suis
sûr ceci vous allez me voir à lui à bâle